hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close
some Geo um Bart you know in the last
couple of podcasts we're talking about
how like um you know in our college
Years like how
like the ideal person we were trying to
date yeah right and it was more about
like it was more lifestyle based like
both you and I didn't really fit into
the stereotypical mold of like the
pickup areas like at the club or just at
a party or at the beach or whatever like
most both both what we were looking for
yeah substance more of the intangible
and those are really hard if you don't
live a
co-existing lifestyle together why are
you smiling at me all the candy I'm
sorry because you have such a small
forehead that that line is already right
by your hair and I was like what the
[ __ ]
sorry go ahead and um
so for me
I was like
like then you as a person
how would you have liked
to been hit on
to sweep you off your feet
like what would be like okay I know what
I want right
then how would I would have been like
whoa this guy's for sure what I want
okay so it's gonna sound like a [ __ ]
movie right why is it gonna sound like a
movie
because it's just it's not real it's
unrealistic what I want
what I did
you didn't do [ __ ]
so it's probably Kentucky
it would have to be
it's right it's again it's going to be
unrealistic okay so this dude would have
to be good looking for one right so he
would have to already be good looking
and not creepy or like his hygiene like
his the first appearance what kind of
good looking like uh God damn like uh
like a uh Tyson like an Italian European
like like
he he looks like he came for money but
he doesn't even have to need money Asian
so that my feelings don't get hurt as
bad
okay like a Korean you know what I mean
from like yeah a little bit yeah yeah
yeah yeah so like uh three percent
that's fine yeah yeah like think K drama
the lead
like that yeah yeah right here yeah yeah
so tall like he look he's like he looks
like he's probably a really good swimmer
okay yeah a little bit more slender or
smaller head okay no no okay so like
that type right like what is that like
clean cut
um while shaven like he looks like he
smells good like
um he can easily fit into like the
European style or like the Korean style
or you with me like the fresa style like
the Mexican like uh what are you this is
you at 25 yeah yeah yeah in my 20s okay
right because then that way you don't
look you don't look immature because
you're not wearing like saggy pants like
you know like you look like you're put
together because you know how to shop
like an adult okay
um your hygiene I'm just assuming he's
gonna be good because if you're wearing
that style of clothing they tend to be
lighter colors okay right so you don't
want to get that dirty
um the materials are more than just
denim so we're talking some different
type of like linen material like maybe
not silk but like that style right pit
bull
oh sure
Yeah Yeah Pitbull Korean pit bull got it
so then that already shows me a lot a
lot right like not only are you not
picking up your clothes from the floor
that you've been wearing the rest of the
whole week prior
um you're clean enough to not get stains
on it yeah your well you're shaving your
hair is combed and I'm assuming that
you're wearing really good cologne yeah
so that already is non-threatening to me
right okay super unrealistic you want a
Korean pit bull who's wearing sunglasses
hair he has hair yes wearing sunglasses
I want to see the eyes
Fades to clear at the bottom it starts
from like a glossy metallic silver to
Black to then clear yeah okay no so you
want a hair you don't like bald guys I
don't like bald guys okay yeah so then
that guy comes into uh we'll just say
I'm studying at the library is this
shirt tucked in or out
half and half like one little thing and
then one little out okay so like uh it
doesn't matter uh that's too geeky for
me a young Keanu Reeves
sure because he's Asian and a little bit
European go look in yeah kind of tall
and he looks good in suits yeah yeah
sure
[ __ ] it we'll go with that I thought
young keanuary was handsome okay you
don't think we'll go with that I really
don't care about the ethnicity by the
way oh okay I'm just trying to paint
like the the the attire and like the
upkeep and the hygiene right like I
don't care about the ethnicity I don't
care about the skin color I don't care
about any of that okay it's just the
initial appearance of how well together
you are okay right like you could be
black you could be Asian he could be
does he look like white does he look
like he benches above 315 or under 315
uh between the 225 range like he has to
do more than late okay so you know what
I mean like I want I want some muscle so
it probably does CrossFit or something
yeah oh that'd be perfect oh [ __ ] he's a
CrossFit okay yeah yeah black white give
it all to me I'm open to all the colors
are they crossfitter I didn't give it to
me okay crossfitter and a uh what the
what crossfitter and like the uh
business casual clothing yeah yeah we'll
do that even though that for me uh is
already boring right but that's
right the white painting the most boring
pictures because that's the most
non-threatening and it paints a really
good picture right off the bat like it's
I don't have to think what do you mean
what's how do you define threatening
um like oh like he doesn't he's not
gonna rape me right now yes yes that's
one of them you think everyone's gonna
rape you
uh for the most part I think all girls
think that they're kind of in danger of
rape on all like at least once a day at
least once a day oh
yes
unless they're like in their house all
day then they're probably pretty they're
feeling pretty safe yeah yeah then why
do girls like like what some girls seem
like they like the attention
because some girls like the attention I
don't know oh it's different all right
okay yeah I don't know I can't speak for
every single female you're asking me why
I want that and that's my because that's
non-threatening so if someone else came
in with like a wife beater backwards cap
and a bulletproof vest on yeah is that
is that threatening or no well that's
already that's already that's not
neutral enough for me that's already
picking too much of one side that I'm
already like okay that's not what I was
just painting 50 Cent yeah that's what I
saw 50 Cent of 2 000. yeah yeah yeah
because 50 Cent now he's like a [ __ ]
he's a businessman now he looks [ __ ]
good yeah yeah
um was I saying yeah so that's so you
have to look that way in order for you
to even strike a conversation with me
for me not to feel
um creeped out by you I don't have your
like exactly exactly so it needs to be
as neutral as possible okay okay right
so I need the person to already look
attractive and like most like most girls
would probably go for that okay a
backpack briefcase or side side bag kind
of guy
it's because you're studying right so
I'm assuming he's coming in to study too
uh
uh no backpack the other one just
briefcase or the other one Side Cycle
whatever the hell is called okay because
in that to me shows like a sense of
maturity
even though it could be false damn I'm
just going based off of Just
my first impression points yeah right
again remember this is super unrealistic
okay keep asking questions this is where
this is great this is okay
and then now what what's your next
question no the same question so what
does he do to oh how would he approach
you to like knock your socks off to know
oh these are the intangible things that
I wanted okay so I'm studying at this
table he's studying at your table
um let's keep a table in between us okay
okay you're not too close no that's
already like it's weird if there's I'm
gonna assume there's a bunch of seating
in this library and like if he's sitting
this one but there's so many other ones
I'm like bro this is your you're already
making a move and I can read it a mile
away don't sit right next to me okay
okay you can sit like in the vicinity
like in my life my side of light my my
line of sight yeah perfect right because
I'm gonna be like oh wow okay okay cool
sits down and it takes this side bag off
yeah get the buckles
okay yeah yeah I want him to study I
want him to show me that he's there for
that okay so he's there yeah
yeah for like 30 minutes it's been
highlighting
yeah and he looks around a little bit
it's like a little mental break you know
yeah yeah now what happens okay
um and then he sees that I'm taking a
break right so maybe I do one of these
things where I'm like you know like you
can clearly tell that I just kind of
need some time away I might get up do
whatever
um then he can get up make his way and
say hey you know what excuse me um this
is really weird and this can even be a
pickup line if you wanted to like he can
all of this would actually work if this
had happened back when you're 25 yeah
all this would have actually worked Yeah
well yeah this will this would have
worked okay
um
uh something to the effect of like hey
I am from your rep
like that [ __ ] it I don't care about the
accent okay fine excuse me yeah yeah uh
excuse me I know that you're interrupted
I know that I'm interrupting you and I I
I'm sorry that I am yeah but like I just
I've never seen
anyone like I just there's just
something about you that I'm just like
really attracted to and I'd be like okay
um thanks okay I know I'm sorry I I look
stupid this is really dumb I don't even
know why I'm doing this right now
um but I just I'll hate myself if like I
lose this opportunity and I never at
least said hi I'm like okay well hi can
I introduce can I give you my name sure
all right my name's Scott Bill Teddy
whatever whatever okay cool nice to meet
you okay well I really would like to run
into you again do you like study here
like a lot like would would that be cool
like if I can just we can at least study
or whatever I'd probably be like yeah
probably not like I'm really focused on
it so even in your dream scenario you
reject them absolutely oh my God you
have to work for the for the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] pain in the ass
yeah how bad do you want it [ __ ]
Okay I'm glad this is your dream come
true yeah I'd be like you know what like
right now it's not really a good time
like I don't know if you would never
hear an actor going like what's your
ideal career like I go and audition
[ __ ] Martin Scorsese is right there
and he goes rejected in your face never
in my town
how many times I say this is unrealistic
yeah but I didn't think it would say
unrealistic in real life
it's unrealistic that's what I'm saying
all right what do you mean in real life
what are we talking about then we're
talking about dreams that no [ __ ] this
is my dreams
so unrealistic in dreams and then
unrealistic in real life is different
well it's just unrealistic in general
all right okay just so I want him to
work for it okay I'm not gonna say yes
all right so you tell them hey no I
don't say yeah yeah I don't think so I'm
not really into it you know yeah it's
like okay well hey and um fine at least
I I shot my shop right okay and then
I want him to uh go away leave me alone
does he get to study still or yeah yeah
he gets to study still and I'd be like
oh [ __ ] all right all right okay go back
studying highlighting okay yeah and then
when I say bye then I then I want him to
be like okay well can I at least know
the next time that you study and I'll
make sure to study far far away from you
but like at least we can just be in the
same space order and I'd be like
you're so weird or I would probably say
some [ __ ] like that like leave me alone
and then I'd probably tell him when I'd
study again
yeah yeah and then that is confusing I
know and this is the [ __ ] this is why
we're all [ __ ] okay that is confusing
I know but you're asking me you can't
you can't [ __ ] want me to be
vulnerable and then judge my
vulnerability all right no no what
you're saying is you're telling everyone
that no means yes
uh if you already if you already look
presentable you look like you're a
responsible person just from the go you
already have to have your [ __ ] together
because I'm looking at every single
little detail if your shoes are a little
too [ __ ] dirty for the rest of that
outfit I'm like hell no I don't trust
you okay so you have your attention to
detail is flawed sir so you would tell
them the next time you're gonna be there
I probably would okay then the next time
happens yeah and then it'd be like huh
we'll see if he shows up okay so let's
say it's uh Wednesday that was Monday
now it's Wednesday yeah Wednesday you
show up and can he come before you yeah
yeah he should he better be there before
me okay so he comes in so he's there and
then now you walk in you see him yeah
now what happens now I would be like wow
I'm actually really impressed why are
you impressed
um you're not like [ __ ] creep I told
him I was gonna be here and he is here
no because that's what I wanted okay
yeah and I'm like oh cool because you
know some people you know the three-day
rule they give them like the number and
obviously you want them to text you but
if they text you right away you're like
oh you're a creep no I've never believed
in that I think that's weird Okay
um so so yeah if he shows up but he's
there ahead of me I'm like oh [ __ ] so
I'm like a priority right now or you
just have really good game like I'm
still my guard is still love but I'm
like I I guess I play a lot of [ __ ]
games you do you sound like you do yeah
yeah I guess I play a lot of games but
you have to jump hoops to be through
hoops to be with me okay all right I
think I'm that [ __ ] cool that like I
deserve a little of that because once
we're together I'm gonna give it to you
like not I'm even talking about sex or
any of that like I'm just gonna make you
my [ __ ]
[ __ ] awesome dude all right still
waiting for that but keep going
swear
this is the best
I've ever had of course but I'm not the
one saying stupid [ __ ] all right fine
um you [ __ ] off where did I leave off
you left off with oh yeah
I'm a priority impressed yeah yeah and
he's there ahead of whatever I said I'm
like dang he's been waiting yeah he's
been winning he's punctual okay yeah you
see his coffee cup and then it's like
halfway down he's been drinking it
looking at all those all the details you
see it yeah and now we better study okay
so he studied where do you do you sit
next to him you sit far away across from
him no we're at the same table now oh my
God fine you've earned the right to be
within my immediate vicinity now
whatever but we're not sitting next to
each other we better stop [ __ ]
studying okay you guys are studying yeah
hour goes by now what happens uh well we
make little small chit chat here and
there who who starts it you do what he
does or is he weird for starting it no
no it's to that point
like but then I do want him to be like
okay fine I I do want you to study I
also need to study like let's get so you
want them to be able to like be focused
and yes okay yes okay
um and then uh you know
plan like how long we need to be there
for and then hey you know what like we
we're here for as long as we needed to
be like right like how long do you need
to study and then I'd probably go like
how long do you need to study for like
good two hours oh cool okay I need about
three is that like I'm gonna study for
three so maybe you can just add two just
head out and then what you want them to
add I don't know I wouldn't want him to
head out oh my God okay all right so
what is he gonna do for the exit what do
you want to do then keep studying with
me until I'm done okay he's like yeah
all right yes but then you would you
would ask him to head out yeah to see
what he does okay I play [ __ ] I can't
say that say it oh yeah yeah so I'm
gonna be here for three but if you need
to go at two like in your two hours feel
free to go in two hours and maybe we can
we can study later okay it's a two hour
mark okay two hour mark oh well it's
been two hours so it's literally the
last page of the book literally the last
page I'm like okay it's not the last
page we're still in the semester corner
or whatever the [ __ ] that's the last
page of the chapter okay yeah bam close
now what do you want to do he's done he
better [ __ ] He's he let us keep him
keep himself busy while I'm [ __ ]
working
and what would he better not leave what
would be to your con what if he leaves
then that chance is over no no not
necessarily because they're like oh [ __ ]
he sticks to what he needs to
just let him I would let him live his
life and I'd be like sick he's not
really controlled by what I want him to
say so that to me I'm like oh okay he's
not being like uh like he won't let me
control the the whole
the whole uh the whole relationship okay
so he goes on his phone then maybe he's
just scrolling
is that cool with you or is that like if
he's on his phone then I'm like you're
just wasting time like that to me is
weird now
but he wants to obviously time it to
that yeah then I want you to be
productive
okay so it goes back to chapter one
all those pages you saw are already
preheated I already highlighted yeah
then good that that to me tells me that
he's further cementing the information
in his head okay but if he's on his
phone I'd be like whoa what a [ __ ]
unproductive thing to do I would judge
so hard really yeah I would judge so
hard holy [ __ ] yeah my standards are
[ __ ] high I'm not gonna be with
someone that's unproductive and you're
gonna jump on your [ __ ] phone that's
[ __ ] what if okay what if he does
this what if he from his [ __ ] Satchel
thing takes out this [ __ ] eye thing
right puts it in his eye and he starts
taking his watch apart
what that's so weird that's weird too
yes so you can't have hobbies long time
wrong place you can't have hobbies he
can't have hobbies and he can't just be
on his phone we're in a [ __ ] Library
he only has one class that's so hard to
believe that is weird I thought it was a
cafe
I said Library oh he's in the library
yes okay
that's weird you pull out a watch and
you start break I'd be like okay that's
uh the end of that relationship damn
yeah I'd be like dude it was so cool
that at that point we're friends now
okay but let's say okay so he's done
studying he only has one hour left and
let's say he only came to the library to
study this one subject she only has this
one book yeah then he could say that
so he's like oh I'm done I only have
this one yeah so now I need to see what
he's going to do with his time
and how he's going to explain that
so what's the ideal oh
um so then
two things could happen he could be like
hey you know what um I only brought this
one thing because it's the only thing I
really need to study and he if he said
if it sounds like it's the truth and
he's like hey like I really didn't bring
anything else but I do want to wait
until you're finished sitting because
I'm hoping that we can get like a bite
to eat
um is it cool if like I come back in an
hour
and like and and we can go get something
I'd be like
all right yeah let's try that
yeah pain of the [ __ ] ass yeah that's
why I don't have many [ __ ] but I
don't have many body counts nor do I
have many guys that I've dated I see
because I'm just like you [ __ ] need
to prove that you're not a [ __ ] loser
I'm the furthest from this guy ever
but you're not because I knew you
already prior to that no I would be
because if I was done
the next hour is me making you laugh
I would literally go behind like a book
aisle and I would take out a book so I
know that you know where I'm standing
and you can't see me because the books
are blocking and I would pull out the
books I could see where I and then plug
it back in and I'll walk down that'd be
pretty funny and I'd walk down two more
feet I think I'd like that too though oh
my God but I am not that clean cut type
of guy right but wait because you
describe like a Ryan Gosling type yeah
but Ryan gobby isn't gonna play funny
games like that we don't know that not
every [ __ ] guy's like that we don't
know that we can't generalize the only
reason why I'm painting such a neutral
dude yeah is because it's the most
non-threatening to me I see right but if
it was you trying to come up to me the
way you're dressed I wouldn't even give
you the time of day the way I'm dressed
right now yeah
the [ __ ] is wrong with this [ __ ] what do
you got against Barbara Brigade nothing
at all just the [ __ ] this is the new
trucker dude look at that
that one goes hard it's our new [ __ ]
trucker yeah okay fine I don't know you
just you wouldn't seem non-threatening
though I wouldn't no you wouldn't why I
don't know what's threatening about me
you're wearing dark colors I don't know
psychologically God are you kidding me I
Gotta Wear some specific colors on the
color wheel I don't know anything for
you keep in mind I don't know anything
about you you look like you could [ __ ]
me up you look like you could rape me
you know what I mean like won't you ask
those questions are you gonna [ __ ] me up
okay that makes sense you know I mean
like I'm not even trying to engage in a
conversation with you I'm probably
buying flip-flops or crop Crocs and you
know I'm not gonna Sprint after you
you're wearing Crocs it's a definite
[ __ ] no I'd be like oh god he's a
[ __ ] Crocker
okay where did we leave off
and then that's it it's just that's what
I would have done with the hour and that
this is I think that's I think that's
funny and I think it was still instead
of who I am that's fine like if you did
that like let's say you're the neutral
color wearing guy and now that hour
you're [ __ ] with me I think I would
let it slide but let's say now we meet
again at the library because I still
probably wouldn't want to go on like
drink date or anything like that I'd
probably want to get food on campus
Because I still don't [ __ ] know you
um like I'd be like no we can stay on
campus like I still got more work to do
or whatever
um I wouldn't go anywhere with your car
like I don't know you so we're staying
where there's [ __ ] enough people I
understand like I'm [ __ ] you know
slow roll this whole date the whole
[ __ ] thing I'm worth it dude okay so
then let's say you're [ __ ] with me
and we're laughing right and you're
doing all that I'll let it slide but
let's say we meet again at the library
because of course we have to meet again
at the library because I am [ __ ]
headed this way and if you're not headed
my direction we are not going down the
same path together
um and you do that again I'd be like yo
you're wasting too much of your goddamn
time
like this is this is this is weird now
so I'll let it slide one time in the
beginning that I was having fun yeah but
after that if I'm saying I need to study
and you're you're preventing me from
doing that then you're wasting my time
you're a pain in the ass yeah
you asked fine well I'm glad I asked
because it's interesting because I I
feel like
a lot of dudes
obviously want to
give their all right when they're like
talking to chicks
but then when you give they're all like
even like the way you're explaining
things it's too much right and that's
where people ruin their chances you can
be the greatest dude in the world but if
you give too much at once it's weird
it's weird right yeah so that's why I
don't even know that's why you gotta eat
things in bite sizes and you have to
have kind of like a logical one thing
leads to another yeah type of thing so
it's it's uh
it's really really interesting yeah I
think for me
my ideal
would be
so
I think as a dude it's definitely not
normal in my time for a girl to hit up
on a guy
it'd be
um
probably how it would be ideal how I
would talk to a girl
say that again like because like our
scenario was how a guy would sweep you
off your feet right yeah I think in 2022
a lot of girls take the first shot now
yeah it's just yeah yeah it's like more
I see and hear about it a lot you know
um like they're just like like girls
would just send a DM like oh I think
you're cute you know like a very it's
much more equalized now yeah
um but when I when I was in college that
definitely never happened right because
there were no DMs or even girls taking
the first shot yeah it's just so rare
you know so in my like I guess uh dream
scenario
or sweep scenario would be still me
being being The Suitor oh and what's
that scenario like what do we need
what's your ideal so for me what does a
girl look like so for me it would be uh
uh I don't even know if that matters
it would matter
um it would be
are you talking talking about college or
yeah yeah we'll do college okay if it's
professional now I have a deep [ __ ]
way higher standards so for me it would
be the gym on campus
because that Venn diagram is ex already
filters out a lot yeah that's why I want
the [ __ ] Library yeah it filters out
a lot because you're in college
and into working out yeah right so
that's already like we're definitely on
the right track yeah and then so it
would be uh me training
and I look and I'm just like trading
during my break
I look around and then maybe I see a
girl either training or running or doing
whatever the Hell she's doing
it doesn't matter what she's wearing
what she looks like hair like none of
that matters uh to me
well then I'm going to go into what
turns me on so what turns me on then is
a high ponytail I like high ponytails
that's like a mid ponytail high
ponytails appear dude oh that's I'm not
talking about [ __ ] 80s weirdo like
like a hype okay and then uh she looks
fit like this isn't like one of those
like New Year's resolution things yeah I
train that's her lifestyle I really do
train yeah and uh she wears like very uh
accentuating clothes
oh so you could kind of see the boobies
you can see the little little bum bum it
doesn't have the boobs don't like just
there doesn't need to be cleavage oh but
whatever she's wearing you need to be
able to see her figure it looks really
good on her okay
and not so much like the hooch you know
but like and it could the Spectrum could
be anywhere from like like Nike
mannequin to like gymshark it could be
in that Spectrum okay right because Nike
mannequin was way more sporty looking
and then the gym shark is more of like
the hooch but then so it could be more
it's not who it's not Hooch but yeah
yeah it's hoocher yeah so in that range
yeah and I see that she's like really
about it like really getting after it
and what's getting after like obviously
the StairMaster would that work doesn't
matter what style she could be
stretching her brains out she could be
sprinting but he can't be like
stretching and she can't touch her toes
like she would have to be touching her
toes because that shows a little
athleticism or you don't even look that
far for me I care about uh intensity got
it so like even with dudes if I go train
with dudes if they're phone trainers I'm
like I don't want to deal with you
gotcha because I'm like we're not even
here for the same reasons like I'm here
to [ __ ] like get after it yeah I'm
not here to watch the game on TV yeah
yeah do a couple curls maybe talk to my
friend got it text text text text you
know yeah like generally when I'm
training I don't even reply to text
unless it's something really important
yeah you know so that's that's the state
of mind I'm like is she getting after it
I don't care what she does if it's yoga
she better be getting after it waits
getting after it treadmill elliptical
getting her after but she needs to be
getting after it okay and then I'm okay
cool it's pretty cool which is not
school she's getting after it was pretty
pretty cool and then uh so afterwards I
see that she's done training because I
hate being interrupted when I'm training
legal and talk to her and I would
probably say something
probably corny and cheesy but it's my
dream scenario so we're just gonna love
everything that I say so then what would
it be so it'd probably be more go oh um
and then let me know what I should say
after okay I'm like uh oh do you usually
train here at like six a.m yeah I do I
love it I'm like dude is that what is
that that's the right way that makes me
happy yeah I do I love it I've never
seen you here before I'm like oh yeah
I'm usually in that section over there
oh cool that section cool I'll keep an
eye out
for you at six in the morning how many
days a week uh are like what are you
training for
um I'm gonna run the marathon I do one
every year oh you're doing whatever yeah
yeah then I would go behind the wall and
scream
he's [ __ ] cool and then jump and
cheer and I'll come by and I'll come
back around am I excited that you left
you're like what was that
yeah I always got to drink some water's
thirsty and I'm like oh cool like so how
often how many times a week do you run
um right now I'm doing a five day
is that too much I don't know you sound
like a freak dude
yeah why do I sound like a freak cause
you went behind a wall
well I'm excited and I'm waiting I know
so you sound like a freak you sound like
you want me to [ __ ] train my balls
off the Met no one runs five days I
don't [ __ ] know tell me what you want
me to do you know what like how let's
just say like three days okay go how
many times a day do you run three days
oh cool I want to get into running too
can I join you I'm in the yeah yeah uh
is that is that what you want yeah that
excitement that would make it easier but
then I'd also be like why is this [ __ ]
so [ __ ] excited
normal yeah but it's your dream my
dreams of course I want it so that makes
me happy in my dream so in your dream
scenario can I be that excited extremely
excited but then I'm all but I'm also
going to look for
what that is grounded in okay so then
what would you what would be the ideal
reply to can I train with you
actually you probably shut me down then
if it's real it's not real it's I said
you're ideal oh am I ideal yeah because
like in my ideal
um I want you to leave oh okay you know
what I mean yeah like this if you have
too much time and you're giving me then
I'm like whoa you know what even in my
ideal she likes to filter [ __ ] out too
she's like oh sure oh yeah I'm actually
gonna run tomorrow at 4am who says that
you do me okay oh yeah sure I'm actually
gonna run tomorrow at 4am would I get in
the way of retraining if I joined you
yeah a little bit no you're gonna say
yes I'm gonna say no oh okay no not at
all oh cool where would I meet you
what does it mean uh you just say uh uh
my house to the gym here yeah that's too
much oh yeah I'll meet you at the mascot
and that's where I like my starting
point is okay I'll meet you at my
starting point it's at the mascot do you
know where that's at yeah that's one of
the big uh big bears cool then I'll see
you tomorrow see you tomorrow and then
end it like that that's what I would
like and and then so what I liked about
that scenario really yeah whatever
[ __ ] weird what I don't even know you
I'm about to [ __ ] run
and at 4am when the sun's not even out
it's dark as [ __ ] a stranger you're okay
with that well that's what I'm saying
for guys it's really hard so even I feel
like if I was dreaming about this I'd be
like
for [ __ ] weird dream
but it's still your ideal but it'd be my
ideal because I don't want to make my
life hard for myself yeah well I don't
either but I I do want to filter for
yeah and that's the first filter okay
which is she said 4am
right so that means you're gonna get
after it and then that already weeds out
a lot of people
not really not not for girls because we
know guys will [ __ ] jump through
hoops no to make it happen so if I was
the girl I'm judging starting at like
350. okay
you know yeah like I'm I'm gonna like if
I was a girl I'm there at 3 30. okay now
what is that that's it that's all you
needed now we get to move on to a
relationship no no now that's so that's
the first start right got it now the
next day you're at the mascot I probably
show up like 3 45. okay and uh just to
make sure that I'm not too weird
I don't know what your pace you're gonna
go at so I'm gonna already pre-stretch
in the parking lot and then when I get
there and you're at the mascot and I see
that you're stretching and then you go
did you stretch yet I'm gonna be like no
even though I did so we could do it
together that's [ __ ] cool you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah so I want to
make sure I'm like not in in with me
yeah I don't want to be like too thirsty
so I'm just like here with you yeah
because then you know how a girl would
receive that if you stretched already
then it's like okay so we're just homies
now then yeah okay just wait for me to
stretch then yeah no I'm like oh no I
didn't stretch yet even though I'm
[ __ ] all limber and loose because I
already stretched because I don't know
where you're at you're all sweaty yeah I
don't know if like you're the type of
chick where I meet you at the mascot
boom you're at [ __ ] just take off
yeah yeah nice so cool so no I go oh
cool I'd love to know what your
stretching routine is at you know I'm
like I'm a world record power lifter so
I'm not too good at the uh the runs oh I
know power lifting is that a good answer
no I'm just kidding I would never say
that but Okay cool so we're stretching
yeah what the [ __ ] dude like stop
playing fight and then so we start going
on our run okay and this is the perfect
thing because let's say it's the long
run days you're such a [ __ ] Meathead
I love this wow okay because we're like
exercising yeah so now it's like or your
exercise what I like about exercise and
getting to know people and exercise or
in an activity like shooting golfing
whatever is I think it occupies your
brain a little bit so that you can
actually really connect as people that's
why I think people even go like oh you
want to go out for coffee because as
you're like going coffee or you're
eating or whatever it's like preoccupied
so there's less of this like like what
do I do with my hands my body yeah yeah
yeah yeah you could be more natural I
see you know even for uh someone that
was Notorious for that is um
I believe Tarantino
like if you feel like the scenes kind of
stiff you'll just give the actor
something to eat uh so the actor's just
walking around just popping nuts in his
mouth yeah you know and then all of a
sudden the scene feels like oh feels
like not so stiff got it so to me I like
to do stuff so
perfect scenario we're going on a run
because if it's a long run it's like 9
or 12 miles that's a lot of conversation
time and so we're just gonna run yeah
that's like a [ __ ] few hours yeah and
then we'll start talking and then
hopefully we can find like common ground
that we connect this is definitely your
dream because there's no [ __ ] way you
can last that long running just straight
off the bat are you kidding me fine go
ahead just kidding so yeah we're running
yeah and we have a good time we start
laughing and stuff and we have just like
a good time and then when we're done how
do you determine it's a good time
same sense of humor very similar goals
um so you want us to get deep in this
conversation like it's a really deep
conversation you just have to be super
deep but it's uh like where are you from
like yeah yeah get to know yeah like
we're like by the time it's the end of
the conversation and I'm just and not
I'm but like the chick is just super
open there's no guard up no wall nothing
yeah is she flirtatious do you like that
is that like one of the things
um not flirtatious yet but she gets my
sense of humor cool so it's just very
friendly yes okay so we do all that
friendly yeah cool so uh she gets my
sense of humor we get to know each other
so that now I know who she is she knows
what who I am cool and then after when
we're done how um what are the things
that needs how do these things need to
to be answered for you to be like sick
we are like I do like like we are
compatible right because like you can be
like well what's your major and I'm like
Taxidermy and you're like okay very
interesting what made you get into that
oh you know what I mean like like
there's certain things that people
answer or how they answer or what they
say that you're gonna be like oh [ __ ]
that's I'm not into any of that [ __ ] or
that doesn't even matter um it needs to
it just needs to be laughing at your
jokes no I like people that have
enthusiasm
um have interest have confidence and
things are rooted in good reasoning okay
you know so if it's like there's a
difference between someone that's like
oh I'm gonna be a doctor on a ball out
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or versus yeah
my parents or versus like oh you have no
control over the first is like I want to
save the world or you know they're all
different you know so I want to like the
I want the ones that like
I Vibe with it gotcha yeah yeah and
that's what I'm trying to pull from you
yeah and then afterwards we're done
running yeah I'm gonna ask her if she
wants to go get breakfast and she turns
me down you turn me down because you're
too busy you're too busy I would love to
but I just have so much your first class
is at seven or something like that yeah
my first class is at seven I mean okay
cool that's that's perfectly fine and
then um then I'm like uh are you cool
with me running with you again yeah
that's so cool that'd be really cool and
then you tell me that it's you're gonna
run a Friday yeah I'm running at Friday
at six are you a Mississippi at four so
I could judge your ass
um now this one this one uh you go like
uh
yeah keep it at four keep it at four
okay yeah I'm gonna do it at four is
that okay with you I know it's really
early do I even say that do I even care
about your feelings does a girl should
she even say that yeah because she's
polite okay I know it's gonna be really
early again I don't know if that's
something that you want oh no that's
okay I could I can make it work cool see
you at four yeah four that's fine what
do we do dabs like does any of that
matter probably a small hug a small hug
we're hugging already yeah
yes I mean we did run for three hours
yeah okay we're connected yeah yeah and
then so now we have fun real quick hook
you know but that's not too close
because we're both sweaty and then uh
Friday run again have a good time and
then afterwards is I want to ask if she
wants to like grab lunch or even do
anything or even do like a hike
um
on the weekend and then she's down and
then that would be like the start of it
and then we trade numbers and then now
that's the start of it super cool man
mine is not the start of it at all what
is yours that's just like the one of
like yeah you have to run a [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] for real it takes months for
me to want to go on a date with anyone
my Jesus God yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah unless this person is literally
like everything I ever wanted which I
don't even know right I'm at that point
like in my 20s that I'm like holy [ __ ]
out or like there's this like attraction
that like I've never felt before with
anyone before you uh where I'm like holy
[ __ ] I need to be around this person I
can't even explain it you know but other
than that like it's you would have to
jump through hoops
yeah that's mine yeah and then for me I
think the next few steps would be uh I
want to see what
what she's about like like let's say
she's like oh yeah I mean I I volunteer
at this lab or I do whatever I'm like
well I want to see
and then we go and hang out I'll be like
just to fly on the wall at the lap and
just doing stuff that she does and then
hopefully by that time we have more like
you know feelings that are reciprocated
and she wants to see what that I do
whatever I'm doing in college and then
she comes and sees some of that you know
yeah or maybe like one of the weekends
uh when I have like drill for the Marine
Corps she drops me off she can see my
base and stuff like that yeah
yeah I like to like see what they're
about they see what I'm about and then
you kind of get more and more and more
of a feel of things you know yeah yeah
that's CUNY that's how I like this to
see things
um for me it would be
figuring all that out right like is this
person creepy like is he running game
like um
um is he like focused does he have his
eye on the prize does he have his
priorities straight and once all of
those questions have been answered and I
feel like oh [ __ ] okay cool I can see a
future then at that point I'd be like
okay we can go on a date and what's a
date like for you
um a date like for me would be like a
fun activity okay um so I would want to
do anything outdoorsy where we can still
talk and connect and then grab dinner
and then talk what's a long time and
then talk that way yeah oh dang yeah
because I like I'm running a bunch of
tests because fun activity to a dinner
that's like a few hours yeah whoa whoa
whoa well I mean it took so long right
where now I'm like okay let's see what's
up with longer stuff and then if that's
cool then everything gets accelerated at
that point
yeah I do a lot of filtering man
you're a pain in the [ __ ] ass yeah
but I think it's I think I think
everyone should hold themselves to that
standard yeah you know that's true and
you should hold yourself to that
standard
um like whatever you're expecting from
others you should be doing that with
yourself first exactly like if I want
someone that looks presentable and not
threatening and their hygiene is on
point or whatever like I need to have
that for myself yeah like if um I'm
looking for the partner that's like uh
gonna be studying and and like goal
oriented and like driven and like
priorities unlock and all of that then I
need to have my [ __ ] together too or
else I'm just a [ __ ] hypocrite so
because I know my shit's on lock I can't
be with anyone that doesn't have their
[ __ ] unlocked so that's why I'm like I'm
holding myself to that standard yeah and
I don't I don't think it's a pain in the
ass at all I never thought it was a pain
in the ass I'm just like this is how I
operate yeah like this is all I know and
this is what I want the tough part with
me is that's how I operated and I'm like
man there's no chicks in my life with me
I'm pretty like this
a ton you're just not looking in the
right places or they're just so focused
that they don't even see that's probably
it you know because I wouldn't see like
if because I'm the 6 a.m at the gym guy
in college yeah when most people are
like waking up at 11 in college or 12
you know yeah and then I'm like I I do
the gym before I even start my first
class and then I want I never I always
want to look like you know me I like to
be before I do yeah right so I would
never go straight from the gym to class
I have to go home and I have to shower
and I have to gel my hair and even
though I'm gonna wear gym looking
clothes it's a huge difference between a
shirt that I already wore in the gym
that has my body heat in it and sweat in
it versus a fresh t-shirt that is fresh
yeah you know so I train
I go back home shower and then I walk
back to class yeah like I never go gym
to class I got like convenience is not
important like doing the right thing is
important yeah to do all that and then
just go throughout my whole life and
then in college like man I had almost
zero chicks and then even the ones that
I did like the the chick that I was
talking to who we ended up going to the
beach with and then I was like oh Biz
[ __ ] got distracted you know
yeah it's just it was just so hard yeah
we probably wouldn't have crossed paths
anyway because I would go to the 7 A.M
classes get all my schoolwork in then
I'd work full time and then after I'd
work then I would go to the gym at night
yeah we were never crossed paths yeah
because I've always traded in the
morning and I'm a business major and
we're way cooler than the [ __ ]
Sciences yeah
so we would yeah under if you did things
the way you did it and I did things the
way I did it and were supposed to meet
under those terms would have never been
not even close
not even close I think it needed to
happen this way where we're already
within the front Circle
and then we were able to see how the
other one operated like I guess
subconsciously because we weren't even
looking at anything specific
um yeah because even like with my
ex-boyfriend like how many times did he
have to visit me at my job before I even
like went out with him it took months
yeah
yeah it's a [ __ ] months it took him
putting a picture of me on it of like on
his shirt to woo me and doing like all
these [ __ ] circus acts for me to be
like all right you're not creepy you're
a little annoying but you're not creepy
I know it was cool with you because it
was funny oh I see you know like for you
for someone to like
um kind of like belittle themselves a
little bit and not like uh like um what
is it called like when the comedians
talk [ __ ] about themselves
self-deprecating yes like to be
self-deprecating for the sake of getting
a laugh I'm like oh [ __ ] cool like
there's a sense of Pride that you need
to shed to be like I don't know it just
felt like um it felt humbling like it
just felt like okay cool like he doesn't
take himself too seriously like that's
fun yeah yeah because in that age
everyone is like I gotta go to school I
gotta be an adult I am an adult oh I
can't wait to get out of here so that I
can just start working you know like
everyone's like too grown up for
everything yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't think I would have ever met
any chicks then because I was just
thinking I'm like man the things that
are on my radar are things to make
myself better and that's all I cared
about
because I always figured like the better
I make myself the higher caliber people
I'm gonna meet anyways yeah the thing is
it'd be like I would just never meet
anyone because there's times where I'm
like I used to run stairs too at the
UCLA Stadium
and so however many you think are in the
gym the people that are running stairs
even less
so I'm like man I'm just gonna be this
[ __ ] loser just just doing my own
thing all the [ __ ] time you know yeah
yeah you're pretty losery yeah I'm just
like a high performing Loser yeah I'm
just [ __ ] a loner all by myself while
I see everyone else just [ __ ] have a
good ass time talking to all the chicks
in the world at these parties I'm like
God damn it I'll never meet anybody
yeah I mean but like you met the most
quality person ever dude
I know but then we didn't make it
through
what do you mean the person that I met
that's the highest quality
[ __ ] off you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] the slow poke up what was your
initial question what was his [ __ ]
what was your initial question that how
do we get here just like uh what would
be the ideal way to sweep you off your
feet you know because you're not the
typical person yeah and so like
um at all yeah you're not typical at all
whereas it's like man like if someone
that doesn't even enjoy people like yeah
well people want and then also the the
traditional like pickles pickup areas
and like well how the [ __ ] does anyone
ever meet anyone like you true yeah
that's true it need it takes a very
unique person then because like let's
say we were to meet like at a club and
I'm probably not gonna go to a club with
like by myself right I'm gonna go with
friends so I'm gonna be like you're
trying to come into my friend space ew
get away
ew yeah
even if they're that super clean cut
neutral and non-threatening Ryan Gosling
dude
uh they'll be like it'll get away yeah
yeah and then um he would probably have
to do some stalking to see where maybe I
go to school or whatever and like run
into me somehow girls are way different
because I'd be like dudes wait you look
like you look familiar did I see you in
a club you know and I'd be like wait is
he stalking me yeah dudes are way
different this is me and my dudes and
some pretty chicks came up and wanted a
horse
[Music]
of course
what do you mean of course how come
girls don't like that because guys
aren't [ __ ] creepy and girls are not
there could be some creepy girls of
course there could be some and those are
the outliers right are they but normally
I don't know are they why can't girls
creep some more then because we're not
creepy we're not thirsty I need them to
be more thirsty no you don't need [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] married with a kid
you don't need [ __ ] are you sure about
that
I think so I [ __ ] think so
yeah I don't know what I would do now
like let's say I was in my 20s now I
don't know I don't know or not no that
doesn't even make let's say you're yeah
we don't we don't work out what would
you do yeah now it's different would you
still be doing the lifestyle you'd be
studying at the library no it'd be
different like now I think I'm looking
for like
um like a super high performer like he
would have to be a [ __ ] stud but it'd
be hard to you it'd be hard right
um like someone that's achieved a lot in
their life like a [ __ ] General
[Laughter]
it's not old like what are you talking
about something to that something to
that effect yeah
um and then I'd be like but why are you
single so you better be [ __ ] widowed
or it should be one of those where you
amicably split up
um and you guys are still some type of
friends oh or would you be like looking
for a guy like uh Jonathan Kim like that
dude who's that the astronaut the guy
that was a Navy SEAL who became a doctor
who became an astronaut
um I would have to see how he balances
all of that with now like relationship
right because I still want a
relationship yeah like I don't want to
to just have this like faint shadow of a
person that I get to see maybe once a
month yeah like you're dating a
superhero that's their one yeah because
then I'd be like uh I'm just gonna be
single and just [ __ ] try to Rule the
World by myself
in my own version I actually follow him
and his posts are crazy like in what way
the [ __ ] that he does is so [ __ ] high
caliber that I don't even know crazier
than Goggins caliber yeah oh yeah all
right all right my bad because whatever
David Goggins did is a stepping stone of
what this guy's pathway is what is he
doing so he's an astronaut now yeah so
he went from Navy SEAL which is what
Goggins did he became a full-fledged MD
okay a physician and then he became an
astronaut
and then so like I think just recently
he did like some crazy flights
um in like some jet that's like went
into outer space
and he was just saying that like uh you
know so you know when you're in those
kind of jets and you're like going like
to the atmosphere the super thin air so
your whole [ __ ] face is like sealed
it's like those kind you know we have
sealed yeah you have like a mask and you
have like a crazy car yeah yeah yeah
yeah so like how do they eat
right so they eat through a tube
so he was talking about like the
spaghetti and meatballs that he ate
through the the tube was actually pretty
good and he's like the shout outs to the
guys that made it oh my [ __ ] I
can't even [ __ ]
imagine what that's tasting like imagine
you're [ __ ] flying upside down and
you just got a sack of spaghetti and
meatballs that you're just like going in
here and going
I'm like this motherfucker's crazy oh
Chef Boyardee you [ __ ] outdid
yourself remember this [ __ ] is
Stellar though I don't know any too many
dudes that are at his level yeah
yeah uh you can't be good at everything
you know yeah so like yeah his career is
probably [ __ ] super amazing but like
how's his family life you know what I'm
saying yeah I think I'd probably be
alone really I think I would be alone I
think because my standards are so gnarly
companionship though
I don't know I think at that point I
would just want to fulfill like maybe
some sexual desires so I might have like
a [ __ ] buddy yeah
um but I would want to leave it as a
[ __ ] buddy like super that
so I even think that [ __ ] buddy would
have to just be like a model looking
person yeah but I don't want to have a
conversation with you I don't want to
have like many like just we leave that
out cool I get to do my own thing you
think your your life would be different
um
if you had custody of taika versus if
you don't have custody 100 really would
be what would be the difference well I
don't have to take care of anyone but
myself so you still that wouldn't make
you yearn more for companionship
[Music]
it takes so much work that I don't think
I would want it no maybe I'm just not
ready yeah maybe I don't think I need it
I'm obviously speaking from a position
of now right yeah who knows yeah you
might not be right but um
yeah I I'm okay by myself
they're gonna be totally okay by myself
yeah because I don't feel like I need
like if I need companionship then I just
hang out with my homies
you know like the only thing I would
that would be missing misting would be
the intimacy part of it
write the sexual stuff but I'm getting
older that's gonna fade eventually yeah
sooner than later but yeah then I'm set
yeah I would uh but then I do hear
women's sex drive uh gets hired I think
it's when they're like 40 or 50 though
or 50 actually I mean well then yeah if
I'm single yeah who knows right yeah I
think I could easily be alone too
why you don't you wouldn't miss
companionship is it because you're
peanut butter [ __ ]
um no I think it's because like I've
invested so much in our relationship
yeah that like
to rebuild what we had
I just know it'd be so much that I would
just be like I'm just gonna chill out
for like two three four five six years
but what if you meet that person again
and you just fall [ __ ] close
and it's effortless I personally would
even be able to click because I already
gave so much in this relationship I have
zero to give
um you know what I mean
yes and no because like when you click
with someone like
you really aren't giving anything you
still have to though I see you still
have to give no matter what true oh [ __ ]
no no no not in a bad way but it just
occupies a lot of bad words
yeah but you want to give it's like this
it's like you'll want to give you know
like you can't wait to give yeah yeah
but yeah for me I just can't see myself
doing like that and I would just be by
myself and I would do the older Bart
version of running the stairs
a plane or a helicopter like I would
just like go more and more [ __ ] to
acquire more like Cool Tools yeah and
and literally run into zero chicks but
what about
leopards and that's it that sounds cool
to you
I think I would get my companionship
through my activities
is so cold and lonely
that wouldn't make you sad
um you're eating your meals all by
yourself in the dark maybe one little
like no I'd probably be like oh [ __ ] my
days are gonna be very maximized
okay I was trying to paint such a sad
sad scenario no my days would be [ __ ]
Matt I might be like I might go like my
whole day of activities
then I'll dine out of Michelin Star Wars
restaurant
right what kind of money you think
you're making here what are you doing
for a living [ __ ] I might just get right
back with you what's going on I think
that I think that's what it destined to
be because I might run I might go to the
Michelin star restaurants and you're
there and I'm like but then but you
gotta it's gonna spend months getting to
know me again yeah yeah yeah there's got
to be a table between us oh right there
you know and uh and it's during the
break where I'm like between my main
course and the dessert I'm like
do you come here often
Bart
yes the your old baby's daddy does that
is
yeah I like the scenario dude yeah it'll
be back together again [ __ ] a I can't
[ __ ] Escape it one of us has to die
in order for this to not be together
that's Kenny like for me I'm So Into
productivity
like I don't think I would
uh if I wasn't a family man I don't
think I would feel loneliness
like I would literally probably be like
um
after I ate between the time that I ate
and I go to sleep I would just call that
recovery time
so I'd probably be in some [ __ ] cryo
chamber or I'd be in a [ __ ] uh
deprivation tank or some sort of like or
getting massages yeah and then it would
just be like I'd be like the ultimate
recovery machine I would just be like
Drago you know yeah like in Rocky it'd
be like I would live like Drago Drago is
[ __ ] hot and just apply myself in
every single phase if Drago came into
the library I'd be like
still right here
he's a good looking dude you know and
I'll just be like like that and then I
would just like okay cool uh I'm gonna
rest this is gonna help me recover so I
could do even more things
and I'll just do more more more and more
and more yeah we're [ __ ] we're stuck
with each other yeah until a [ __ ] I'm
like flying a plane one day and then I
see another chick flying away
hey that's crazy do you fly up here
every Wednesday
do you uh fly up here every Wednesday
yeah maybe like that this is looking
cute well damn that was a good ass
question dude you really made me like
get into that headspace going like yeah
what is it like I have we haven't dated
in how many goddamn years over a decade
how many years way more than a decade
how many years have we been together so
next year is going to be 15 years you
mean what about this year this is 14
yeah
I like how like
[ __ ] subtract one yeah oh I can't
believe you have these high standards
you can't even do math
hey I did I faked it till I mixed it
yeah fine all right anything else you
want to add nope all right then that's
it thank you guys so much for listening
and keep your [ __ ] standards High who
gives a [ __ ] how annoying you the other
person might think you are filter out
the [ __ ] weaklings get the [ __ ]
cream of the crop amen hallelujah
adios